for most of us thinking is at least
somewhat unpleasant
we try to avoid it where possible for
example i asked these guys how long does
it take for the earth to go around the
sun
what do you reckon cuz is it 24 hours
obviously a day yes or take this problem
which has been given to thousands of
college students
you go into a toy store and there's a
toy bat
and a toy ball together they cost a
dollar ten
and the bat costs a dollar more than the
ball
how much does the ball cost
we're all wrong aren't we what
if you think about it for just a second
it's obvious that the ball can't cost 10
cents
because if it did then the bat would
cost a dollar ten and the two items
together would cost a dollar twenty
the correct answer is five cents now the
point of these questions is not that
they're difficult
any of these people could have quickly
checked their answer if they wanted to
the point is that they don't check
because thinking
is uncomfortable it takes effort
hey the earth doesn't take one day to
get around the sun
it takes a year
now i think it would be easy to put
these mistakes down to stupidity
and believe that you being much smarter
could never fall into such traps
but then i think you'd be fooling
yourself i think these examples reveal
blind spots in
all of our thinking due to the
fundamental way that our brains work
now one way of modeling how the brain
operates is as though there are
two systems at work psychologists call
them system one and system two but
maybe it's useful to think of them as
characters so let's call
system 1 gun and system 2 drew
you are drew he represents your
conscious thought the voice in your head
i am who you think you are he's the one
capable of following instructions he can
execute a series of steps
if you're asked to calculate 13 times 17
in your head for example he's the one
who has to do it can i just use my
calculator
no all right um 17 times drew is lazy
it takes effort to get drew to do
anything and he is slow but he's the
careful one capable of catching and
fixing mistakes
221 now meet system 1 gun
he is incredibly quick which he needs to
be since he's constantly processing
copious amounts of information coming in
through your senses
he picks out the relevant bits and
discards the rest
which is most of it and he works
automatically
without you drew being consciously aware
of what he is doing
for example when you spot some text he
reads it before you can even decide
whether or not you want to read it
gun fills in the gaps for example what
does this say
did you notice that the h and the and
the a and cat are
actually the same symbol but you had no
trouble reading it because gunn made the
correct automatic assumption
so although drew is unaware of what gun
is doing it's guns perceptions that
become the basis for your conscious
thoughts
the way i like to think of it each of
these characters is related to one of
your main memory structures
gun's automatic responses are made
possible by long-term memory
the library of experiences you've built
up over your lifetime
in contrast drew exists entirely within
working memory so he's only capable of
holding four
or five novel things in mind at a time
this is perhaps one of the best known
findings from psychology
that our capacity to hold and manipulate
novel information is
incredibly limited like when trying to
remember a string of random numbers
6 7 5 5
3 1. yes
but we are able to overcome these
limitations if the information is
familiar to us
for example let me give you four random
digits 7
1 zero two now these would normally take
up
most of your working memory capacity
just to remember but if you reverse them
2017 they are now just one thing the
present year
the process of grouping things together
according to your prior knowledge is
called chunking
and you can actually hold four or five
chunks in working memory at once
so the larger the chunks the more
information you can actively manipulate
at one time learning is in the process
of building
more and bigger chunks by storing and
further connecting information in
long-term memory
essentially passing off tasks from drew
to gun
but in order for this to happen drew
first has to engage with the information
actively and effortfully often multiple
times
for example when you were first learning
to tie your shoelaces you probably
recited a rhyme to help you remember
what to do next
using up all your working memory in the
process but after doing it over and over
and over again
it gradually became automatic that is
drew doesn't have to think about it
anymore because
guns got it musicians and sports stars
refer to this
as muscle memory though of course the
memory is not in the muscles
it's still in the brain just controlled
by gun you can
practice everything exactly as it is and
exactly as it's written
but at just such a speed that you have
to think about and
know exactly where you are and what your
fingers are doing and what it feels like
slow deliberate conscious practice
repeated often enough
leads to this
i bet 99 of the time what appears to be
superhuman ability
comes down to the incredible automation
skills of gun developed through the
painstaking deliberate practice of drew
what's interesting is it's actually
possible to see how hard drew is working
just by looking at someone
try this task i'm going to show you four
digits i want you to read them out loud
and then after two beats
i want you to say each number back on
the beat but adding one to each digit
so as an example seven two nine one
should be eight three
zero two this is called the add one task
and it forces drew to hold these digits
in memory while making manipulations to
them now it's important to say the
numbers back on the beat
try this one
to make it harder you can try adding
three instead of one
ready
now what you're unaware of is that as
you're completing this task your pupils
are dilating
when drew is hard at work as he is in
this task you have a physiological
response including increased heart rate
sweat production and pupil dilation
watch how the pupils of these
participants enlarge
as they perform the add one and add
three tasks four
three nine seven two
five four zero eight
three excellent nicely done
this requires a lot of thinking i know
that's the point
six nine one six
seven zero two seven
when this research was originally
carried out the researchers made a
surprising observation
when the participants were not engaged
with the task but were just chatting
with the experimenters
their pupils didn't really dilate at all
this
indicates that the add one and add three
tasks are particularly strenuous for
system two
and that most of our day-to-day life is
a stroll for drew
with most tasks handled automatically by
gun just as we spend a lot of our lives
lounging around our brains spend most of
their time doing the mental equivalent
and i don't mean to make that sound like
a bad thing this is how our brains
evolved to make the best use of
resources
for repetitive tasks we developed
automatic ways of doing things reserving
drew's
limited capacity for things that really
need our attention but in some
circumstances there can be mix-ups
for example i moved to australia in 2004
and one of the first things i learned
was that turn the lights on you flick
the switch down
my whole life growing up in canada gun
had automated that up
means on so no matter how well i drew
knew that down was on in australia i
would for years continually switch the
lights off when entering a room
and on when leaving when destin learned
to ride the backwards bicycle
with its steering reversed it took
months to overcome his automated habit
and
once he had done that he couldn't easily
go back to riding a normal bike
understanding gun and drew also explains
errors in the baton ball question
it's gun who first perceives the key
pieces of information that together the
baton ball cost a dollar ten
the bat costs a dollar more than the
ball so the ball costs 10 cents
10 cents gunn immediately had an answer
that he blurted out automatically
meanwhile drew without being consciously
aware that the answer came from gunn
endorsed the idea without checking it
after all the answers sounded reasonable
and drew is lazy
so how do you get drew to do more work
well researchers have found at least one
way
when they gave out a clearly printed
test including the baton ball question
to incoming college students
85 got at least one wrong but when they
printed the test
in a hard to read font with poor
contrast the error rate dropped to 35
percent
a harder to read test resulted in more
correct answers
and the explanation for this is simple
since gunn can't quickly jump to an
answer
he hands off the task to drew who then
invests the required mental effort to
reason his way to the correct answer
when something is confusing drew works
harder and when drew works harder you're
more likely to reach the right answer
and remember the experience this is
something i think the advertising
industry knows about and is using
to its advantage a few years ago again
in australia i saw
a giant billboard that had just two
letters on it on
there was no logo no indication of what
it was for and this seems to go against
all the basic principles of advertising
to show what the product does how it's
better than the competition
and use clear branding and maybe a
jingle to make it memorable
the goal is usually to make the message
as easy to understand as possible so
drew doesn't have to work very hard
but if you look at a lot of effective
advertising today it's changed to be
more confusing
as the un campaign rolled out across
sydney i saw ads like this one in bus
shelters
unexplained with un there is no stress
just unstress
no hassle just unhassle with un you can
undo what you did you can
un-drive through the car wash with the
window down or un-break dance in front
of your teenage son
and his mates un makes life relaxing and
unreal on your life be happy and live
for now
don't worry unworry can you guess what
the ads were for
they're actually for insurance now that
advertising is everywhere gun is skilled
at filtering it out
it's automatic if i just saw another
insurance ad i never would have given it
a second thought but
something that doesn't make sense that's
something gunn can't deal with so he
hands it off to drew
this same realization has been happening
in education lectures which have long
been the dominant teaching method
are now on the decline like the old form
of advertising they're too easy to tune
out and often especially in science
lectures
too many new pieces of information are
presented and that exceeds drew's
capacity because he doesn't have big
enough chunks to break the material into
in place of lectures universities are
introducing workshops peer instruction
and formats where students are forced to
answer more questions do more work than
just listen and take
notes and this will undoubtedly make
drew work harder
which is good because that's how
learning happens but a lot of students
don't like it because it requires more
effort
just as it's hard to motivate someone to
get off the couch and exercise
it's hard to get drew to give his full
effort there's an appeal to doing things
you already know
for the musician to play the same
familiar songs that gunn has already
automated that feel and sound good to
watch videos
that give you the sensation of
understanding without actually learning
anything to always drive with the gps on
so you never get lost but you also
never learn the way if you really want
to learn and get better at anything
have any chance of becoming an expert
you have to be willing to be
uncomfortable
because thinking takes effort it
involves fighting through confusion and
for most of us that's at least somewhat
[Music]
unpleasant
foreign